this is the Panamanian golden frog a  frog so rare it may no longer exist in  the wild merely inches in size this  program eight skin is stunning but also  quite poisonous the Frog is covered in  deadly toxins to protect itself from  predators in the wild it feasts on  insects that it finds near streams in  the mountainous rainforests of Panama  but a combination of deforestation  poaching and a devastating fungal  disease laid waste to their population  but there is still hope for this special  amphibian breeding in captivity has been  successful and continued efforts are  being made to protect and preserve their  habitat this is the Panamanian golden  frog